could we make a moon orbit in a square  instead of a circle sure if we have  enough moons  if all you have is one moon directly  orbiting a planet then closed orbits are  limited to circles and ellipses  but let's say you had a moon that orbits  a moon that orbits a planet you might  call it a moon moon  it's actually what they're called  anyway the moon moon may still orbit the  moon in a circle or an ellipse but its  orbit around the planet might have curls  in it  we can take this a step farther though  the more moons we have orbiting other  moons the more interesting the orbital  shape  with enough moons in just the right  orbits that last one on the outside  could easily orbit in a square  or the letter n  or even my logo if you want to be super  fancy  i wonder if this is what rich people  will do in the future instead of putting  their names on buildings